nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
le Pakistan figure parmi les pays les
plus touchés par les événements
météorologiques extrêmes du haut
dérèglement climatique les terribles
inondations de ces derniers mois dans le
sud en témoigne un tiers du pays sous
les eaux et ce n'est pas fini vous allez
le voir près de 2000 morts des dégâts
considérables pourtant le Pakistan né
responsable que de 1% des émissions
mondiales de gaz à effet de serre Sony
agezali on vous retrouve en duplex
d'islabab vous êtes la correspondante de
France 24 au Pakistan vous vous êtes
intéressé à cette forme d'injustice
climatique en vous rendant dans une des
régions les plus dévastées par ces
inondations
oui on s'est rendu dans le signe dans le
sud du Pakistan qui est l'une des
provinces les plus pauvres du pays et
c'est l'une des plus sinistrées suite
aux inondations qui ont frappé le
Pakistan en août dernier suite à une
mousson exceptionnelle mais ce qui est
aussi assez symptomatique du
réchauffement climatique au Pakistan
c'est que cette même province a été
fortement touchée par la vague de
chaleur qui s'est abattu sur le Pakistan
en mai dernier avec des températures
record avoisinant les 51 degrés faisant
de jacobabad et Dadou dans le signe les
villes les plus chaudes au monde à ce
jour encore dans le signe il y a
plusieurs villes qui sont toujours sous
les eaux qui sont toujours inondés oui
on va le découvrir grâce à des images
spectaculaires Pakistan alerte rouge
pour le climat reportage de Shahi Zab
wallah Sonia guezzali avec la
collaboration de Samir mandro
[Musique]
les plaines du cygne dans le sud du
Pakistan ont des allures d'océan
de mois après les pluies dit leviennent
d'une mousson historique le contenu de
stagner des milliers de familles
sinistrées vivent isolés coupés du reste
du pays par les eaux
leur survie dépend des sauveteurs qui
assurent leur ravitaillement
nous sommes en route pour la ville de
Gozo qui est encerclée par les eaux
depuis deux mois et il y a une pénurie
de nourriture là-bas nous acheminons de
l'aide
nous avons de la farine des lentilles de
l'huile et d'autres produits
alimentaires nous allons les distribuer
aux gens
on mène ce genre d'opération depuis un
mois et demi vous voyez toute cette zone
là et bien c'était des villes il y avait
des gens qui vivaient là des maisons il
y avait tout un réseau de route des
marchés et autour de ces villes il y
avait des champs agricoles et maintenant
cette zone ressemble à un océan partout
vous regardez vous ne voyez que de l'eau
[Musique]
le niveau d'eau ici est de 3m50 vous
voyez cette rame elle mesure 2 mètres de
long regardez je la plonge entièrement
dans l'eau et elle ne touche pas le sol
cela montre que l'eau est profonde d'au
moins trois mètres
il y a 2 mois il y avait 6 mètres de
profondeur donc le niveau de l'eau n'a
même pas baissé de moitié pour l'instant
la ville de Gozo entourée d'une
vingtaine de villages c'est transformé
en île
plus de 400 familles vivent ici et
dépendent de l'aide alimentaire
internationales et du gouvernement
[Musique]
Puna les pères de quatre enfants en bas
âge il doit sa survie et celle de sa
famille à ses rations alimentaires
il a presque tout perdu dans les
inondations
effondré
maintenant nous avons étendu ces tissus
pour avoir un peu d'intimité vous voyez
là notre cour est rempli d'ordures que
les inondations ont amené
ici c'est très sale et il y a aussi
beaucoup d'insectes
sont recouverts de toiles d'araignées à
cause des inondations toutes les
araignées ont envahi les arbres
c'est très épais et même si on nettoie
ça revient en quelques heures
regardez ça
c'est le type d'araignée qu'il y a
partout c'est très difficile pour nous
il y a tellement d'insectes et nous
vivons à ciel ouvert
la famille vit comme dans une décharge à
ciel ouvert
infestée d'insectes encerclé par une eau
insalubre un cauchemar qui dure depuis
près de huit semaines
de nombreuses parties du village sont
inondées j'ai des enfants et j'ai peur
pour eux j'ai peur qu'ils tombent dans
l'eau et qu'il se noie parfois je les
enferme dans la chambre et puis il y a
beaucoup de maladies la gastro-entérite
le paludisme si mes enfants tombent
malades comment puis-je les emmener à
l'hôpital les routes sont inondées on
doit louer un bateau pour se déplacer
mais on n'a pas d'argent pour ça
plus de 22 000 enfants ont été
hospitalisés dans les zones inondées
dans le sud du pays
nombreux ont été accueillis dans cet
hôpital pour enfants
l'eau stagnante et les conditions ne vie
épouvantables ont causé des épidémies de
diarrhée de paludisme d'infection
respiratoires aiguë d'infections de la
peau et des yeux de typhoïde et d'autres
maladies
les hôpitaux comme celui-ci sont
débordés
le docteur Ikra ne compte plus ses
heures
[Musique]
dans notre village il y a de l'eau
partout il n'y a pas de médecin pas de
clinique ou aller cela nous a pris plus
d'une semaine pour emmener notre fille
ici
elle avait été soignée avant son
paludisme ne serait pas devenu si grave
elle aurait pu être guéri depuis un
moment mais les inondations rendent les
choses compliquées pour les patients les
hôpitaux sont surchargés nous avons
parfois jusqu'à quatre patients par lit
on ne peut pas traiter correctement les
patients et cela engendre des
complications médicales
faute de personnel médical suffisant les
parents veillent 24 heures sur 24 sur
leurs enfants malades
nazabibi accompagne sa petite fille qui
a contracté une pneumonie
comme nous sommes pauvres nous avons
d'abord donné des médicaments
traditionnels à ma petite fille mais
cela n'a rien fait puis j'ai décidé de
venir ici mais en chemin quelqu'un m'a
volé et a pris tout l'argent que j'avais
j'avais même plus d'argent pour payer le
transport
[Musique]
l'une de mes filles a été blessée dans
les inondations son bras est cassé et
elle a perdu la vue
en virgule 6 millions d'enfants ont
besoin d'un traitement
urgent dans les zones touchées par les
inondations dans le sud du Pakistan
chaque jour près d'une vingtaine
d'enfants succombent à leur maladie dans
cet hôpital
cette femme effondrée reçoit le corps
sans vie de son bébé mort des suites
d'une hépatite
arrivée trop tard à l'hôpital il n'a pas
pu être sauvé par les équipes médicales
[Musique]
soutenu par sa mère elle repart avec son
nourrisson dans son village non des
[Musique]
agoso nous retrouvons punal si la
plupart des échoppes dans sa ville reste
porte close car trop endommagée lui a pu
reprendre son travail il est serveur
dans un salon de thé traditionnel les
murs ont été emportés par les eaux
déchaînés il ne reste plus que les bancs
faute de clients Puna a perdu 60% de son
salaire et gagne au moins d'un euro par
jour
[Musique]
l'inquiétude se lit sur tous les visages
la chose qu'on craint le plus c'est la
pluie s'il pleut encore comment faire
notre maison n'a plus de toi comment on
va abriter nos enfants nous ne gagnons
presque plus rien mon salaire ne nous
permet même pas de nous nourrir alors
comment songer à la reconstruction de
nos maisons nous avons tellement de
difficultés et nous avons peur qu'il y
ait d'autres inondations qui cela arrive
nous mourrons le Pakistan responsable de
moins de 1% des émissions mondiales de
gaz à effet de serre et l'un des pays
les plus touchés par le réchauffement
climatique une réalité que chacun ignore
ici
je ne sais pas d'où vient cette eau mais
la quantité est énorme dans cette vie il
y avait 5 mètres de profondeur d'eau
quand les inondations sont arrivées
c'était le chaos ici comme si c'était
l'apocalypse les gens couraient pour
essayer de trouver refuge sur la terre
ferme
est-ce que vous êtes au courant du
changement climatique non pas du tout
certains disent que ces inondations sont
une conspiration occidentale que les
Occidentaux nous ont envoyé des gros
nuages d'autres disent que ce sont nos
propres dirigeants qui sont derrière
tout ça qui nous ont noyés pour obtenir
de l'aide étrangère mais on est pas sûr
de ça car nous sommes il est très
la population dans les zones rurales du
signe et l'une des plus pauvres du
Pakistan le taux d'alphabétisation y est
l'un des plus bas depuis quelques années
un homme tente de sensibiliser cette
frange vulnérable en première ligne du
réchauffement climatique son auditoire
ce jour-là ces femmes qui récoltent le
coton et qui ont perdu leur travail les
champs étant détruit
au-dessus du ciel vous savez qu'il y a
le soleil le soleil envoie de la chaleur
à la terre entre le Soleil et la Terre
il y a une couche protectrice qui filtre
les mauvais rayons vous savez que les
températures sont plus élevées
maintenant
ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a de la
chaleur provenant de la terre mais parce
que cette couche protectrice est amincie
et maintenant les mauvais rayons
arrivent directement sur la terre et
c'est pour ça qu'il est température ont
augmenté la raison pour laquelle cela se
produit c'est que les voitures et les
usines qui brûlent du carburant provoque
une pollution qui s'élève dans les airs
et endommage la couche protectrice
secondaire le plus important est que les
températures augmentent et que cela
provoque des catastrophes naturelles à
répétitions il y a donc maintenant une
menace d'inondation récurrente nous
devons nous y préparer
[Musique]
la première chose à faire et que nous
devons créer des lieux de stockage des
céréales dans les villages pour assurer
une sécurité alimentaire
deuxièmement nous devons construire un
système de drainage qui peut drainer
l'eau et ainsi sécuriser les villages et
troisièmement et c'est le plus important
les maisons doivent être construites
plus en hauteur de sorte que si l'eau
arrive à ce niveau par exemple elle ne
peut pas rentrer dans les maisons et
vous pouvez rester en sécurité chez vous
avez appris de cette discussion
aujourd'hui
nous avons très bien compris pourquoi
ces catastrophes se produisent nous
sommes analphabètes on vit isoler nous
ne savions rien de tout cela avant
maintenant nous avons compris que nous
devons avoir un bon système d'évacuation
des eaux que nous devons économiser des
céréales en cas d'urgence pour pouvoir
survivre
nous sommes ceux qui contribuent le
moins aux émissions de gaz carbonique
mais nous sommes ceux qui en souffrent
le plus l'industrie textile repose
littéralement sur leurs épaules
elles sont celles qui récoltent le coton
elles permettent aux usines de faire des
profits mais l'industrie ne leur rend
pas et ça c'est justement au cœur du
concept de la justice climatique c'est
comment impliquer les acteurs locaux
nationaux et internationaux et faire en
sorte que les grandes entreprises
internationales comme Adidas par exemple
les dommages
les groupes qui utilisent les énergies
fossiles doivent compenser en crédit
carbone
et en tant que citoyen je pense que la
justice climatique doit être instaurée
sur le plan international
[Musique]
le coût des dégâts causé par les
inondations au Pakistan s'élèvent à 30
milliards de dollars selon les autorités
il faudra plusieurs années au pays pour
se relever après cette catastrophe
climatique
[Musique]
et on retrouve Sonia Gazali en duplex
d'islamaba Sonia on voit bien que cette
question de l'injustice climatique est
en train de prendre consistance
notamment à l'occasion de la COP 27 qui
se tient en Égypte
oui en effet le Pakistan a énormément
souffert de l'impact du réchauffement
climatique cette année et c'est ce que
compte justement faire entendre faire
notifier les autorités pakistanaises qui
sont sur place et elle compte également
rappeler à tout ces pays riches qui sont
largement responsables du réchauffement
climatique et bien quelles ont une
responsabilité en 2009 les pays riches
se sont engagés à verser chaque année
100 milliards de dollars à tous les pays
vulnérables qui font face aux graves
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
depuis 2020 mais depuis 2020 chaque
année cette somme n'a jamais été versée
entièrement il est temps que les pays
riches soient responsables fassent face
à leurs responsabilités assument c'est
ce que nous a dit chez les Mann qui est
la ministre du changement climatique au
Pakistan
il devient intenable que des conférences
comme celle-ci n'aborde pas le cœur du
problème à savoir l'injustice cl les
pays qui font partie du club des 1% les
super riches des super riches doivent
dédommager les autres 1% qui sont ceux
qui polluent le moins c'est à dire nous
alors Sonia s'il est pays riches versent
toutes les compensations prévues telles
que le Pakistan notamment le demande
est-ce que cela peut avoir une incidence
sur le destin des populations notamment
dans la région vous avez tourné
et bien elle pourrait aider dans
l'immédiat ses populations à
reconstruire leur maison elle pourrait
aider le Pakistan à reconduire à
reconstruire toutes ces infrastructures
qui ont été détruites dans les
inondations du mois d'août mais cela ne
changera pas le destin de ce pays qui
est sur la ligne de front du changement
climatique il y aura d'autres
catastrophes climatiques dans les années
à venir les autorités pakistanaises en
sont bien conscientes une partie de la
population le C également les autorités
s'attendent à ce qu'une partie de la
population des zones qui risquent d'être
le plus touché comme celle du signe et
bien finissent par partir s'installer
dans les villes et cela provoquait donc
un exode climatique
correspondante de France 24 au Pakistan
merci Sonia c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]